do you think
gptn can achieve consciousness
well
gptn probably it's not even clear for
the present systems and I talked to my
friends at open AI they feel that this
question whether the models currently
are conscious is much more complicated
than many people might think I guess
that it's not that the open AI has a
homogeneous opinion about this but
there's some aspects to this one is of
course this language model has written a
lot of text in which people were
conscious or described their own
Consciousness and it's emulating this
and if it's conscious it's probably not
conscious in a way that is close to the
way in which human beings are conscious
but
while it is going through these states
and going through 100 step function that
is emulating adjacent brain states that
require a degree of self-reflection it
can also create a model of an observer
that is reflecting itself in real time
and describe what that's like and while
this model is a deep fake our own
Consciousness is also as if it's virtual
right it's not physical our
Consciousness is a representation of a
self reflexive Observer that only exists
in patterns of interaction between cells
so it is not a physical object in the
sense that exists in base reality but
it's really a representational object
that develops its causal power only from
a certain modeling perspective it's
virtual yes and so to which degree is
the virtuality of the Consciousness in
chat GPT more virtual and less causal
than the virtuality of our own
consciousness
but you could say it doesn't count it
doesn't count much more than the
consciousness of a character in a novel
right it's important for the reader to
have the outcome the artifact of their
model is describing in the text
generated by the author of the book what
it's like to be conscious in a
particular situation and performs the
necessary inferences
but the task of creating coherence in
real time in a self-organizing system by
keeping yourself coherent so the system
is reflexive that is something that the
language models don't need to do so
there is no cost or need for the system
to be conscious in the same way as we
are
and for me it would be very interesting
to experiment with this to basically
build a system like a cat probably
should be careful at first build
something that's more that's limited
it's limited resources that we can
control and study how systems notice a
self model how they became become
self-aware in real time
and I think it might be a good idea to
not start with a language model but to
start from scratch using principles of
self-organization
is it okay can you elaborate why you
think that is so self-organization so
this kind of
radical legality that you see in the
biological systems why can't you start
with a language model what what's your
intuition
my intuition is that the language models
that we are building are golumps they
are machines that you give a task and
they're going to execute the task until
some condition is met and there's nobody
home
and the way in which nobody is home
leads to that system doing things that
are undesirable in a particular context
so you have that thing talking to a
child and maybe it says something that
could be shocking and traumatic to the
child or you have that thing writing a
speech and it introduces errors in the
speech that new human being would ever
do if they're responsible right but the
system doesn't know who's talking to
whom there is no ground truth that the
system is embedded into and of course we
can create an external tool that is
prompting our language model always into
the same semblance of round twos but and
it's not take the internal structure is
causally produced by the needs of a
being to survive in the universe it is
uh produced by imitating structure on
the internet
yeah but so can we in in externally
inject into it this kind of
coherent
approximation of a world model that has
to
sync up maybe it is sufficient to uh use
the Transformer with the different dos
function that optimizes for short-term
coherence rather than next token
prediction over the long run
that we had many definitions of
intelligence and history of Fai next
token prediction was not very high up on
them
and there are some similarities like
cognition as data compression is an old
Trope
um solomonov induction where you are
trying to understand intelligence as
predicting future observations from past
observations which is intrinsic to data
compression and predictive quoting is a
paradigm this boundary between
neuroscience and physics and computer
science
so it's not something that is completely
alien but this radical thing that you
only do next token prediction and see
what happens
um is something where most people I
think were surprised that this works so
well so so simple but is it really that
much more radical than just the idea of
compression as intelligence as
compression
um the idea that compression is
sufficient to produce all the desired
behaviors yeah is a very radical idea
and but equally radical as the next
token prediction
it's something that wouldn't work in
biological organisms I believe
biological organisms have something like
next frame prediction for our perceptual
system where we try to filter out
principal components out of the
perceptual data and build hierarchies
over them to track the world but our
Behavior ultimately is directed by
hundreds of physiological and probably
dozens of Social and a few cognitive
needs that are intrinsic to us that are
in this built into the system as
reflexes and direct us until we can
transcend them and replace them by
Instrumental behavior that relates to
our higher goals and also seems so much
more complicated and messy the next
frame prediction even the idea of frame
seems counterbiological yes of course
there's not this degree of simultaneity
in the biological system but again I
don't know whether this is actually an
optimization if we imitate biology here
because creating something like
simultaneous necessary for many
processes that happen in the brain and
you see the outcome of that by
synchronized brain waves which suggests
that there is indeed synchronization
going on but the synchronization creates
overhead and this overhead is going to
make the cells more expensive to run and
you need more redundancy and it makes
the system slower so if you can build a
system in which these simultaneously
gets engineered into it maybe you have a
benefit that you can exploit that is not
available to the biological system and
that you should not discard right away
you tweeted once again quote when I
talked to Chad gbt I'm talking to an NPC
was going to be interesting and perhaps
scary is when AI becomes a first person
player uh so what does that step look
like I'd really like that tweet
that step between NPC to first person
player
what's required for that
is that kind of what we've been talking
about
this kind of in external source of
coherence and inspiration of how to take
the leap into the unknown that we humans
do the search man search for meaning
llm's search for meaning
I don't know if the language model is
the right Paradigm because it is doing
too much it's giving you too much and
it's hard once you have too much to take
away from it again
the way in which our own mind works is
not that we train a language model in
our own mind and after the language
model is there we build a personal self
on top of it that then relates to the
world
there is something that is being built
right there is a game engine that is
being built there is a language of
thought that is being developed that
allows different parts of the mind to
talk to each other and this is a bit of
a speculative hypothesis that is
language of Sword is there but I suspect
that it's important for the way in which
our own minds work and
building these principles into a system
might be more straightforward way to a
first person AI so to something that
first creates an intentional self and
then creates a personal self so the way
in which this seems to be working I
think is that when the game engine is
built in your mind it's not just
following Radiance where you are
stimulated by the environment and then
end up with having a solution to how the
world works I suspect that building this
game engine in your own mind
does require intelligence it's a
constructive task
where at times you need to reason
and
this is a task that we are fulfilling in
the first years of our life
so during the first year of its life an
infant is building a lot of structure
about the world that does inquire
experiments and some first principles
reasoning and so on and in this time
there is usually no personal self there
is a first person perspective but it's
not a person this notion that you are a
human being that is interacting in a
social context and is confronted within
immutable World in which objects are
fixed and can no longer be changed in
which the dream can no longer be
influenced as something that emerges a
little bit later in our life and I
personally suspect that this is
something that our ancestors had known
and we have forgotten
because I suspect that it's damn plain
sight in Genesis 1 in this first book of
the Bible where it's being described
that this creative spirit is hovering
over the substrate and then is creating
a boundary between the word model and
sphere of ideas Earth and Heaven as
they're being described there and then
it's uh creating
um contrast and then time engines and
then space and then it creates organic
shapes and solids and liquids and builds
about from them and creates plants and
animals gives them all their names and
once that's done it creates another
spirit in its own image but it creates
it as man and woman as something that
thinks of itself as a human being and
puts it into this world
and the Christians mistranslate this I
suspect when they say this is the
description of the creation of the
physical Universe by a supernatural
being I think this is literally a
description of how in every mind a
universe is being created as some kind
of game engine
by a creative Spirit our first
Consciousness that emerges in our minds
even before we are born
and that creates the the interaction
between organism and world and once that
is built and trained the personal self
is being created and we only remember
being the personal self we no longer
remember how we created the game engine
so God in this View
is the first creative mind in there it's
the first Consciousness in the early
days in the early months yes of
development and if you go there do you
still have this outer mind that creates
your sense of your of whether you're
being loved by the world or not
and what your place in the world is
right it's something that is not
yourself that is producing this it's
your mind that does it so there is an
outer mind that basically is an agent
that determines who you are with respect
to the world and while you are stuck
being that personal self in this world
until you get to Stage six and to
destroy the boundary
right and we all do this I think earlier
in a small glimpses and maybe sometimes
we can remember what it was like when we
were a small child and get some glimpses
into how it's been but for most people
that rarely happens